yo what up what up it's your boy where's
khalifa man and make sure y'all check me
out on the bootleg cav
podcast
yo bootleg cab show special guest my
good friend is here
what's happening by the way man liquid
death yeah yeah
sponsored by liquid death today yeah
yeah for sure where's khalifa man
what's good man good to see you good to
see you too buddy it's been a little
while it has been a while man i feel
like um
i think the last time we did an
interview or something we did something
on like instagram during the
uh we did like ig live it was when i was
dropping music last year
yeah and then we did uh the mcqueen
summer party thing we did the mcqueen
party for sure
which was yeah the whole the whole
entire pandemic had [ __ ] doing
weird ass [ __ ] like i was dj
huh i said you caught cove it didn't oh
yeah i had it you never caught it
i did you did i feel like we all did i
did
i caught it that week when l.a had like
opened up like pump faked on us
and i went to nobu and i went to the
studio and then
i couldn't taste or smell anything i
remember that that was like
i remember it was like end of may or was
it
june it was early june it was early june
and everybody it was it was like all of
a sudden this mental thing happened
where we all just thought it was over
i was in [ __ ] scottsdale turning the
[ __ ] up djing and
i got i got caught with the pump fake
yeah
and then i was like wait a minute i
can't smell mm-hmm that's the word
i mean i could still taste and i didn't
really have any like crazy symptoms
outside of that
it was random i was eating breakfast
and i was like couldn't taste the orange
juice i'm like this is weird maybe it's
just like bad orange juice or something
so i'll go upstairs i got all these
essential oils and stuff and i'm like
shoving peppermint up my nose and i'm
like no i can't smell
nuts yeah my wife was cooking and i
couldn't smell anything and i was like
oh [ __ ] i just got home from from like a
weekend out nazi
and uh my dog has like this little piece
of grass like artificial grass
that he'd be [ __ ] on sometimes and
there was like a turd on it
and i was like yo this is the ultimate
test so i got down
i was like i don't smell this [ __ ] it's
in front of me i got covered
and then just the whole crib ended up
with it so the [ __ ] test yeah we were we
were locked down man
uh but yeah i mean it feels like
everybody's kind of
finally getting through did you get
vaccinated no i didn't get vaccinated
are you like not gonna do it or
i'm not uh just hasn't happened totally
against it yeah it just hasn't happened
yet
they talking all that [ __ ] about
traveling and stuff like that yeah it'll
probably help
you specifically we'll see some of these
countries
you know we'll see i'm not against it
i'm just not in any rush either
i hear you i i get both sides like i
like i got homies that are like yo
like i want to see the first year of
this [ __ ] pass that makes sense
and then let's see you know cause like a
lot of people got the johnson and
johnson one
and then they pulled that [ __ ] off the
shelf yeah right so yeah i got i just
got my [ __ ] out the way though you got
it oh yeah yeah
i'm not yeah i don't think i'm not one
of those people who think people are
stupid for getting it
there's i mean you know it's probably
going to be
some type of consequences we'll [ __ ]
see
what kind of consequences do you think
though uh
me personally yeah population control
i do i mean listen the population
control
dark hole is a serious one especially
when you start considering like
just i feel like there's so much [ __ ]
going on when we start talking about
like elon musk and
going to planets and you know
the resources on earth at the rate that
we're creating people
it's like it's some something's got to
give eventually i don't know if we're
going to be here when it happens
who knows but i can see that yeah it's
real it's real
i mean and there's there's people that
twisted to come up with stuff
to actually do that well you know and
the other thing too is is like
the idea that uh kovit
came from a lab was so frowned upon
initially when you would say that
because uh you know it's [ __ ] up like
nowadays like
if you if you have any sort of
perspective or bring up any sort of
opinion that doesn't go with either side
of
you know society they they label you as
the other side
yeah you know what i mean so it's like
hey there is some like real
clues that would make you think that
this came from a lab
but if you said that a year ago people
be like
you're a mega trump freak but it's like
wait
like it's not it's possible to like
think for yourself sometimes without you
having to be on you know right yeah i
mean i mean this thing it gave it gave a
lot even just the vaccinations
it just gives a lot of people some [ __ ]
to argue about
everything man oh i got one oh i don't
have one oh
i want one oh you don't want one oh
you're dumb for wanting one
oh you're stupid for not wanting one i
just want to stay off twitter and the
internet man
this just gives people some [ __ ] to
argue about the brands
of [ __ ] uh vaccinations
give people bragging rights and [ __ ]
like that i'm a modern mommy
it's weird i stay away from i know you
got to because you're
in it every day like you have to report
back on that [ __ ]
yeah but me like i keep it so far away
because like it becomes your reality
after a while like
it also [ __ ] with your energy yeah i
mean you know
i feel like i feel like you've done a
really good job of
i don't like i don't ever see whiz
participating in
just [ __ ] online nah i know my place
and you know like you'll throw a thought
out there and then everyone else will
react to it yeah okay
you'll throw some [ __ ] out there like yo
don't be around me if you're smoking
backwards
right and then it'll go on every [ __ ]
like hip-hop meme page and then everyone
chimes in and then
you're probably smoking you know i mean
like on some g [ __ ]
i don't even look at this stuff
afterwards like i'll say something and
then i'll just sit my phone down that's
how you almost got to do it yeah
otherwise you drive yourself crazy
reading comments you drop [ __ ] three
interviews a week and if i dived into
the comments on these interviews yeah
no god blew like a culture vulture
i just go on about my day like yeah i
don't even realize how many people i
piss off but it's cool though because
people need to be pissed off
people need to you know have
conversations like you said like
alternative conversations
yeah i just think that we've gotten to
the point and and you know i think the
trump [ __ ] is a lot to blame with this
yeah where everyone is so tribal with
their thoughts
to where like you know if you don't
agree on
everything over here that side will just
tell you to go [ __ ] themselves you know
i was talking to killer mike
and uh you know mike is a big gun
advocate
right which is okay but like
he's also with bernie sanders in alabama
advocating for unions for amazon workers
but there's like people who like agree
with killer mike on
everything else that will hang him out
the dry because he he believes in the
second amendment right
and it's like what the [ __ ] like yeah
you should be able to believe in
whatever you want to
sometimes i talk about it too like yeah
that's the real part is like
you really can't say [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying it's like
it shouldn't be like that to where one
conversation will just
spark everybody calling you these names
or thinking you're just
like we can we can just talk about it
maybe i need to learn some [ __ ] that i
didn't even [ __ ]
know a point of view on it or whatever
whatever but
to be able to bring the conversation up
and not have to you know
be boxed in or labeled oh my god and
have your whole day ruined by
you know other people's opinions that
you don't deserve all of that
that's a hundred percent it's crazy uh
did you you know i'm a big joe rogan fan
and
uh i went there uh with uh freddie gibbs
did his podcast like
a couple months ago and we went out
there yeah yeah ditched rooms with joe
oh sweet my [ __ ] face was melted off
y'all did the shrooms on the show
no no no we did him that night at a
comedy show
it was rough y'all ate just like regular
strong so i [ __ ] up because i ate an
edible
uh-huh um like a a pretty strong edible
and then i ate shrooms and i was
drinking like a fish
and then we went to sixth uh sixth ave
or sixth street sixth street
and we went bar hopping in bro yeah in
austin yeah oh yeah cause he moved his
show down yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it was probably a
really it was a really rough trip for me
because i really thought that like
we were gonna get killed [ __ ] it i was
paranoid as [ __ ] i thought everybody was
trying to like smoke freddie i was like
bro we don't end up like pop smoke out
here bro like i was really freaking the
[ __ ] out
and then i got them and i just woke up
in my hotel room yeah yeah
it was rough but um but you went on the
rogan show which i thought was super
dope
did you get like i feel like that's
another guy who we're talking about who
like just speaks freely for three or
four hours at a time so he's bound to
say some [ __ ] that can piss
any amount of people off did you get any
like blow back from anybody for
no man actually i got a lot of love from
that of course
it was a great interview thank you
appreciate it you guys were highs [ __ ]
we were stoned i i just woke up i was
really excited to do it
first of all and then when i got there
there was no like real format or
anything
it was just like yo just sit down and we
just start talking so
um yeah i mean the vibe that i got from
him
and of course is is authentic and he's a
cool ass dude
but he just says what he thinks is is
real and what he believes and if he
believes it he believes it if he doesn't
he'll actually talk to you but he's not
really going to challenge your opinion
he's just going to say what he believes
and i i i'm i'm cool with that like
everybody's standing on i also like the
fact he's very
open to your perspective right like he'd
be like oh [ __ ] i didn't even look at it
that way you know what i mean like he
has people from all
sides see nobody get on there argue with
joe they just talk
everybody just talks but they don't
always agree they're not saying the same
exact thing
but they're not [ __ ] going back and
forth and [ __ ] i feel like if the world
was like that'd be big
are we just yelling at each other yeah i
mean and he's or tweeting at each other
really
with lots of caps yeah it's weird i
don't even [ __ ] with
a lot of that type of stuff y'all are my
homies so it's like y'all could get
anything you know what i mean but
really like on the outside and you know
uh
just shock value and all of that stuff
click bait
it's it's a dark real scary place and
i'll take that [ __ ] personally
like like for real for real if somebody
uses me
for a headline yeah that's not cool like
that's not what we in it for so
even try to set people up like that and
make things out of we
i've never been in it for that well i
feel like you also don't do a lot of
like you do interviews but you're not
like you don't do like a lot of sit-down
[ __ ] like yeah you know what i mean like
i feel like i was just thinking about it
earlier today i don't i don't do a lot
of that but
well i do but it doesn't go crazy
because nobody
[ __ ] with me like nobody and i feel
like you're very good
at when someone tries to hit you with
one of those got you joints
right you just shut that [ __ ] down yeah
for sure i mean it's
it's definitely a mutual respect where
i'm like okay you you got to do what you
got to do you got to try to get these
questions off
but i'm not going to break my character
or you know my integrity
for your headlines you dig what i'm
saying we're going to keep it light
we're going gonna keep it cool and if
that's not interesting then you don't
even want whiz you know what i'm saying
but i'm not coming here for no drama
or no [ __ ] and i think people really
understand that and they don't really
approach me with that they don't try to
bring that out
and yeah i feel very fortunate to have
that be a part of my career you dick
yeah 100
man um are you still heavy in the gym
because man your transformation just as
a dude
yeah it's pretty serious i used to be
little as hell bro i mean yeah like you
know you were whiz just
just skinny skinny tall skinny cat and
then all of a sudden
yeah you're yolked up doing kickboxing
and all that man
it was definitely like inspiring to see
like how committed you were to not only
like
getting bigger and getting like stronger
but also just the
the fighting [ __ ] that's like like it
felt like you were all like you're all
in on that
yeah 100 um like for me like
i'm not trying to be the biggest dude in
the world the biggest gym freak or
anything like that right
i think i just kind of started just to
learn and the more that i started that
that i would be able to put like the gym
aspect just into life or music or
whatever
art creativity science excuse me
it all just made more sense and kind of
tied in and um
of course you get the physical benefits
from it if you stick with it
like you can't just do what i did in
like six to eight months
uh it takes years to like transform your
body you know what i'm saying and i'm
still
in the process of you know keeping it
going and um because you were
you were training with uh jay glaze yeah
yeah still i still
am there yep and um yeah i mean
you know there's a lot of layers to that
bro like there's
there's the the the business layers uh
i became an owner in the psl yeah i was
gonna get to that yeah
we got gyms all over i'm gonna have my
own protein shake and
stuff like that like based off of it um
there's like the family aspect bro i
know so many fighters around the
country around the world we can go to
any gym we can go to any
you know what i mean it feels like when
you have something like that in common
with someone it's almost like a
brotherhood because you're like you're
like in your most vulnerable space with
these guys
training sweating like you know what i
mean like you're probably as a rapper
you're so used to being in situations
where you're that [ __ ]
like yo you're headlining every show
you're on everyone's there to see you
you go to a gym with a bunch of killers
it's like
you know you're in a different position
it's definitely humbling
and um you know anybody who comes from
like our position we just want to learn
so i feel like that was always my goal
so when you
get to a point in rap where i'm at where
you're not really
learning too much from anybody around
you you want to be
the new guy at something and you want to
have you've mastered the rap game you
want some ogs around you you don't want
to
you know i mean always be the one who
everybody's looking to for everything
and uh the gym definitely allows me to
do that with the
pfl how did you get involved in that
because for people
there's like they just did an espn deal
on my uh my producers
yeah that's a big deal man super big um
yeah so it's been going on for about two
three years now uh
so you're you're a part owner of pfl
yeah yep
um and basically it's just alternative
to the other fighting leagues
and um we have a regular season and we
have playoffs and we have a championship
and other superstars who competed other
places they can come to the pfl
and join the season and we go off of a
point system
so the people with the most points
that's who advances in their weight
class
is it similar to like i think a point
system i think like the way nascar does
it is it kind of close to that i don't
know [ __ ] about nascar
i just know that they do i just know
i mean i could learn about nascar so
instead so essentially
because that's a new way of doing it
because you're talking about season you
know we're so used to seeing ufc it's a
pay-per-view thing it's like
so this is like more like like may the
best person win
whoever's got the end of the points goes
to the play is it like playoffs yeah
it's playoffs for show and then
championship fire
um you know clarissa shills yeah female
boxers she crossed over to the pfl so
she's making her mma
debut with us over there
so it's going to be a lot of stuff like
that where you see maybe people from
other sports crossover or people who are
superstars in other uh other leagues
they might not have you know got their
championship shot
but they come to the pfl would um would
you guys take on
like celebrity fights yeah like if one
of these paul bros were like hey man i'm
trying to get in the octagon
why not i don't see why not we would
train them up
we would start them in the season and
see how far they go yeah
i mean you got to compete like it's not
going to be like a popularity contest
so yeah i think that that's what those
dudes they bang like they really fight
that's what i've been trying to i mean
like look man like i'm a you know if
you're a boxing fan you got to at least
be excited that um
there's attention on the sport again
right because on the because on the
undercards of these fights there's some
real boxing music
i mean like the actual fights that we've
seen so far haven't been like real
fights they've been more like
exhibitions or right right
you know what i'm saying it's like you
know we get in there but
the way that they train and what they're
prepared for they really
they're really fighting you know i mean
they're not just taking pictures or
going to the gym and
[ __ ] warming up and looking good like
they're they're getting it in
yeah mm-hmm i think that uh that'd be
crazy so
what what do you think would
differentiate the pfl
from because you know there's bellator
there's there's ufc i would say those
are probably the big two right right
but you guys got an espn deal which is
all automatically great because
you you know you got eyes behind it but
what what kind of differentiates what
you guys do
or or makes what you guys do unique
compared to those two
um it's more for the fighters and for
the fans
um not to say that take away from any
other
corporation but uh yeah we just keep
both in mind we want the fighters to
make money
as well as gain popularity and we want
the fans to get the best
uh bang for their buck so you know you
have your lower tier
you could start here and then you got
your uh
you mean gets a little bit higher and
then you got your top tier so
you you're getting what you spend your
money on and what you spend your time
paying attention i do feel like that's
one thing we always hear about ufc is
that the fighters kind of get
paid yeah the fighters are fairly the
fed the fighters
have issues they have gripes yeah yeah
yeah cause you'll see some of these
pay-per-view numbers and then you'll
hear what someone made who fought and
you'd be like
yeah there's happening i forget what the
exact numbers are but there's
only a handful of um you know those
fighters who have actually fought for
a million dollars or more and that's
what our main prize is is at the end of
it you get a million dollars if you win
and the championship
oh i mean yeah that's that's a that's
awesome [ __ ] you it's a no-brainer
um train hard win a meal where are you
at with music right now because i feel
like at this point in time
you just do what you want so sometimes
we'll we'll get a a random tape from you
mm-hmm
well you know you're you're hopping on
songs that
with people you who you [ __ ] with um
you know last year we got the ep but
like what do you
how do you feel about i mean by the way
love the fact finally last year we got
cushion or juice on spotify yeah that
was a big [ __ ] deal yeah everybody
was [ __ ] with that that's funny but
yeah like how
where are you at music wise man are you
still inspired are you still
like like you know how do you feel about
about the rap game right now
i love the way that the rap game is
moving now i think a lot of the
work that i put in and paved the way on
is like paying off not only for me but
for a lot of other people
facts so um you know with that in mind
uh i just i i see uh
the next step in my evolution and i'm
always working on it i'm always in the
studio i'm always working with new
artists and things like that but for my
own
personal project the next thing for me
is to just
you know have have another big moment
that is stand out
not just to other people but really
impresses me
and um i know what i want to talk about
and i know what i want the numbers to
look like
and i know what you know type of people
i want to impress
but i can't get there until i actually
create the project
so that's what i'm doing is i'm making
the sound and i'm getting the content
and everything that i
really think is gonna you know take me
to the next level in a lot of different
people's opinions as well as mine and um
you know that's working with different
production working with different
writers
um just trying to put together not
really trying but putting together
a full ass project that's going to be
the evolution of you know who i am in my
career
yeah i feel like you've gotten to the
place in your career where like
sure you'll take another cu again right
because it's one of the biggest songs of
all time right
but at the same time you're with khalifa
like you're a [ __ ]
you know i think that there's probably
three other guys like in your category
as far as just like
my grandma knows who you are you know
what i mean like
um so like that's it gives you freedom
kind of
because you can just make what you want
and you can like you said like you're
you're trying to craft a project or a
new sound or
like you could be as patient as you want
yeah like my main thing is the message
so if the message isn't right or not
even that is not right but if
if it's not telling the message of the
music yeah the message and the music
yeah absolutely
if it's not uh if it's
i don't want to just scratch the surface
or because i've already done that i'm in
the game i'm deep in the game
so i'm just being really really
conscious of
the things that i say and i love
what's being made in music now but
there's
no way that i could say that and be
completely fulfilled
and it takes time you know what i mean
it takes time to really put together of
a full meal for [ __ ] to really
digest and
and enjoy and um you know everything
that i
make i feel like is fire but it's like i
i'm
if you go fishing you can't catch every
fish like i want that big fish
so i'm really just shaving the fat and
what is the message that you want to
like put out there in the news there's a
lot of different things
um with with young artists um
there's way too much violence with with
the younger artists man i just had this
this kid fulio from jacksonville here
and i had to like
i was like really trying to talk to him
like hey man like
i don't know if they got this beef going
on out there this is
so crazy so disrespectful like the
violence is crazy and it's
yeah there's so much of that and that's
what these blogs are feeding
our timelines too and it just feels like
yeah it almost seems like dudes are like
getting into it to start beefing with
each other like that's why you got into
rap to get like
so out of it yeah and if you think about
like you know wrestling piece of king
vaughn but like
the issue between him and quando rondo
like those guys aren't even from the
same city right
so like that was a wrap beef rabbit it'd
be different if like king von got into
it with someone from chicago while he
was in atlanta but yo guys are dying
over rap beef
it's not productive for anybody and and
no one's
like where are the companies that are
behind these guys or the
the big homies you know what i'm saying
like well the labels are signing them
because that's what's like fueling it
and making it go further
because it's it's not really in their
hands it's like
it gets like just this type of the songs
that they play and the the words that
they say
how disrespectful they are to people's
families it's insane
it wouldn't be it wouldn't affect the
same
if it wasn't mainstream i agree if you
had to dig deep to find that stuff
then it wouldn't affect it the same but
there is
people who have nothing to do with any
of that
singing it in the club or riding around
in their car listening to yourself it
feels it puts so much
more onto it than actually would be
there if it was just beef
did you see the uh vanessa carlton remix
the thousand miles remix where they're
like on the golf course
you know it's it's it's crazy yeah yeah
you should have a reference here
but yeah put it in now this kid young
and ace put out
you know a thousand miles with the white
girl song from white chicks if i could
why
yeah they redid that song and literally
just did a whole entire song three
minutes straight just talking [ __ ] about
their ops dead friends by name that's
crazy it's insane
and it's like 25 [ __ ] million views
and it's like damn
yeah that's the type of [ __ ] what are we
doing
yeah i mean you should like
yeah so you're so you kind of want to
come in and because i feel like there's
no balance right now especially with the
younger kids man like you know i think
there's like kids like cordee that are
amazing and yeah but as far as just like
there's it feels like there's a whole
generation that's just well i'm just
speaking from a perspective of not
preaching to nobody because i'm still
living my life
too of course but i'm jotting i'm not no
washed up [ __ ] that you could just be
like oh shut the [ __ ] up we don't want
to hear what you got to say it's like
nah you
have a choice whether you want to listen
to what i'm saying but i'm going to say
it though
so like i'm i'm definitely touching on
subjects from a from a perspective of
i've been through it
mm-hmm i had to come out of pittsburgh
to get to where i'm at
and i would never want to go back to
those circumstances that
man i was in when i was you know coming
up we had chevy here
and chevy told the story about how they
just tried to kill him not too long
right and he wasn't in the game he's
been out here
he's an og and you know we all know
chevy chevy's a great guy but it's like
you just
you know you just never know man when
you come from that world especially when
you're back home man it feels like back
homes are you always going to get the
most haters
yeah i mean you know the goal is to try
to be able to operate your business
without worrying about any of that stuff
right
and i just want to definitely uh
push people in in the direction of you
could still be cool
you could still you know be that [ __ ]
you could blah blah blah be
safe like you don't have to show money
you don't have to show guns you don't
have to
disrespect anybody and if you really got
a problem with somebody there's
a place to take it where you could be
tough but like that's another thing is a
lot of dudes would rather shoot and
fight
yeah you can also try to resolve the
situation yeah talking
i know you've had success i know you've
had situations that were resolved
off camera i've had a lot of situations
that people don't even know about 100
because it's not even that serious you
know if you really want to get to the
bottom of it you
can and um yeah so and
that's what the gym does too for me
because
a lot of people do think they're tough
and they want to they want to fight they
want to throw hands
and they'll say in a heartbeat oh i'm
not going to no gym i'll shoot it out
blah blah blah
i think that's cause you can't last
three minutes you actually can't fight
you don't have the cardio skills
i've seen you swing like a [ __ ] right
right so you don't want to get
embarrassed
you know what i'm saying so remove that
from it
and really get it off your chest if it's
really an issue
there's a lot of rappers securities
who'll be acting tough and you know my
big homies
of course they're like look we're
starting a security fight i was gonna
say you're you're security for people
who don't know
his security got their whole [ __ ]
fighting league in vegas
all y'all big [ __ ] who want to
be frowning in the club and all that
[ __ ]
they'll get put in the armbar quick yeah
bring it to the mat
be productive you know what i'm saying
we could all get money after that we can
get money out of the situation
but you know bring it bring it there a
lot of [ __ ] ain't signing up
but you know we'll see what it is but at
least there's an alternative and we're
we're trying to
put it on a mainstream level of we're
not with
that other [ __ ] we're with this this is
what we're doing we're doing martial
arts
right we're working together we're doing
this we put [ __ ] on the road together
we work out when we're on the road
and of course [ __ ] gonna have problems
you don't have beef but like you said
what's the alternative
to you know uh resolving the situation
um you've always had the
like one of the best ears in hip-hop i
feel like when it comes to just
new talent like i feel like you're
always
you know even when you know i just think
back to all the times like i first heard
somebody was with you when you were
djing in a bungalow
i mean in vegas like oh what's this oh
[ __ ]
um you know i think i really think like
the first time i ever heard uzi was with
you and this was uh [ __ ] i don't even
know how many years ago that was maybe
2015 or something
um like you know how tapped in do you
try to stay i mean obviously you have
taylor gang you sign artists and all
that but like just
as a fan like do you do you still like
because sometimes
i'll be feeling like man i'm so busy i
can't even i don't even got time to be a
fan of this [ __ ] no more yeah
you know what i mean as far as just
discovering new artists and
you know but like like do you still even
have time to even be a fan
or and try to find new artists you know
not even for your label but just in
general
yeah just in general um yeah i think
just the game
and music consumption has changed a lot
and that race to find that new [ __ ] has
just been
become like everybody's so thirsty now
like
[ __ ] is just digging and like reaching
for what's new or what's hot
and for me i like to just see what
what i enjoy and a lot of the time i
just stumble
on it or my homies will play it or
my son now he plays a lot of new music
and [ __ ] that i never even heard before
and i don't even really have to search
for that [ __ ] no more
it comes to you yeah it just it just
kind of pops up but in those days that
you were talking about
like that was a lot of fun because that
was really
you know uh
a selection of music it was like all
right i'm not listening to none of that
this is the [ __ ] that i like
and that was what more would i like to
put out to the world is what i
enjoy whether people like it or not post
malone was one of them first
[ __ ] like
there's a lot of people whereas like i
just supported them just because
i know even 21 savage i remember you
playing 21 savage super early super
early
yeah i pulled up to him at one of his
shows just because like i [ __ ] with
his vibe
and i had been in atlanta you know
recording some music getting some
tattoos and [ __ ]
and it just you know just rubbed off the
the correct way but
i think it's really important to to
just be open and sensitive to all of
that [ __ ]
and even right now with the world about
to be back open
i already know what my playlist is going
to sound like it's not going to sound
like everybody else's
because that's not the vibe that i want
to bring i want to
inspire a different feeling i want to
have a different groove
so there's going to be some [ __ ] that
you don't know there's going to be some
[ __ ] that you do know
and [ __ ] we just going to have a good
time yo have to stop the bootleg podcast
real quick and shout out our sponsor odd
socks
that's right they've been holding this
down from the jump man and they're
not only the makers of the most
comfortable socks in the world shout out
to odd socks
but they also now got the drawls man
the boxer briefs are so fire they're so
soft
they feel great on your ass you're nuts
whatever you're into
you know what i'm saying whatever you
got they'll cover them up real real
comfortably
and ladies you know you could wear these
things to sleep so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev save 20 off
you know
one of the licenses they just got that i
love are the naruto socks they just got
the naruto socks
of course they got wwe those are mankind
socks ladies and gentlemen
spongebob and shout out to the the goat
ric flair so what you got to do get you
some odd socks
thank me later save 20 off at checkout
by using the keyword bootleg kev
at oddssocksoficial.com and we are
super proud that they're presenting this
podcast let's get back to it i feel like
too what was dope about the pandemic is
it made people listen to music
differently
it made us like instead of standing on
couches
at the club and you know hearing [ __ ]
that way
i think that there was like a resurgence
of
you know some real rap [ __ ] popping off
do you think so
i think so because i think i just look
at the grammy nominations right it was
freddy gibbs it was uh voice the five
nine
d smoke yeah it was it was it was just
all some real
like real rap [ __ ] that i think that
might have gotten overlooked in other
years because i feel like
we're listening in headphones we're
listening at home you know what i'm
saying i think the content for this year
changed because everybody just became
more conscious of what was going on
around them
yeah and people tried to make more songs
that were geared towards that
as opposed to like you know what i mean
different different things
in my opinion it made people dig a
little bit
deeper yeah i think like yo griselda had
a crazy year last year
yeah i'm saying like it's definitely
like the vibe has changed for sure
due to like what you're saying people's
attention span
but i want to get back in the club
though like [ __ ] that oh i know you do
i want to stand on the couch for sure on
the couch that's inspiration
hey going back to your uh uh your
freshman cover in 2010
that was a in retrospect one of the
most historical covers i think they ever
had at double excel was you it was nip
it was big sean it was fred it was
j-rock
j-rock was on uh cole was on there like
such like like how crazy like do you
ever like look back and
and kind of reflect on like some of your
moments in hip-hop because that's like a
historical moment man
yeah yeah it's dope um
when you're coming up you always you
look at the past and be like oh man i
wish i would have
came up there in that time but we
definitely had our own era where it was
like that was
our golden era you could say it was like
how it was when
tribe was out yeah it was like i was
looking my favorite era was the blog era
that was our own version of that and we
lived it too we were
couch surfing we were flight hopping we
were concert
going we were studio sleeping
we was really thugging and we everybody
was helping each other out so it was all
the
like you said the blog air we made the
music and then the blogs put it out so
we had
it was the relationship it was always
fun to find new artists on like two dope
boys
like those days it was like it was just
it felt like that the
curators there was more of a selection
to where you knew if you went to a
certain website you find some [ __ ] that
you're looking for i feel like nowadays
the curators like a few people at these
dsps
it was hard to get into those things too
like you really had to be dope
no for sure but it was like but they
would also take chances on artists yeah
for sure
i mean for show you they would post one
thing if it didn't get that many likes
they would still post another one
yeah thank you man this popularity
contest now
um which is cool it's it's not that bad
but
that [ __ ] only lasts what 15 seconds so
yeah i feel like the streaming [ __ ] is
cool but it's like also
it's made it extremely i wouldn't say
hard but i feel like
you it's harder than ever to
start from scratch and have a career
because you really got there's like a
few
i'm someone on some independent [ __ ]
there's you know you got to get on carl
cherry's radar you got to get on
you know whoever's to really kind of
break through some of those um editorial
playlists do you think so
i think so man i think you just gotta
get a good 15 seconds
what do you mean michael the song that's
it um
you're good all right yep you have to
have a whole song you got 15 seconds a
nice little hook
tick-tock little something that loops
put it on tick-tock you're good
hey you had a tick-tock moment something
new you made a little the fans did that
that's something new but i was like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is like two years old
exactly yeah fans did that that was cool
as hell
that happened during the pandemic too it
did it did everybody was at home with
their families
take talking it up using the app and all
that
you mentioned your son bash um who you
know i think is
probably intellectually like one of the
smartest kids
that kid is how old is your son now
eight i wasn't saying he's probably
eight going on like 15
as far as his brain like he's a very
smart kid he's sharp
yeah he's a very sharp kid um you know i
i thought it was dope to see you do the
oriole commercial recently
um what is it about how you and amber
have raised him that
that you know i think i think to like
how i see
a lot of fathers with their kids and
like like what do you think is special
about how you guys decided to raise him
is there anything like that you would
give as far as like
advice to other parents out there um i
think we both share
a lot of the same views if not pretty
much all of them
on how he should be raised and
that's really important to be on the
same page with your partner
because you're you're trying you have to
there's a push in the pool some people
might want to see that kid grow up this
way some people might want to see it
grow up that way
and from what i've learned is that's
really just personal with the parents
and if you're grown enough and brave
enough to let that go for the better
of the kid then that's when they're able
to benefit
so you know there's some days where
he might not want to go to school and
she might be like all right cool
and if he's with her that's her rules
you dig what i'm saying
right right all right cool your mom said
you played some hooky today yeah yeah
oh your mom blah blah blah you need to
be you let you completely let that go
and it is what it is
he's with me oh looking we eat
mcdonald's today
you know she's like oh cool he deserves
a cheeseburger he's been good
right now don't be feeding my baby you
know what i mean there's a lot of little
stuff that starts there the little stuff
like you got to be able to get along and
then
when it comes to make big decisions then
you right there on the same page and
there's no friction
and um that's how me and her are as like
we we start with those little blocks and
he's a really good kid he's really
understanding he's really
you know fortunate we live right down
the street from each other right so he
gets to spend a lot of time with both of
us he's not really missing out on
too much so is he on the road blocks yo
he's robloxed out
being that roblox yeah he's he's roblox
and in fortnite for sure i didn't
realize that roblox was a publicly
traded company until recently
and i bought some stock because i was
like i know how much [ __ ] money i'd
be i'll be putting into that roblox for
my
damn game seven year old up and they go
up and down though
yeah they find the company that makes
the game that makes all of them yeah
exactly because even fortnight like
fortnight's kind of
you know it was a wave and now it's you
know they go up and down bro
you you're not like a big gamer right
now man i don't game that should take
too much time out of my day
like yeah it's a lie dude it's almost
like
it's fun but then you just feel like
[ __ ] man like you're not being very
productive with your day i used to play
games but
i started rapping when i was 14 so
like that whole muscle of sitting down
and doing that that i don't even have
that bro like
i just like i love seeing snoop on
twitch when he rage quits
oh yeah i love that [ __ ] he really means
it too like
oh yeah that's not no acting or none of
that [ __ ] like he'd really be hot bro
like snoopy upset
um we were talking about mushrooms
earlier yes
talk to me about the craziest trip
you've had because a lot of people take
mushrooms they micro dose and they get
through their day and then there's other
you do that uh what do they call it the
master dose or the
no no no like the super dose yeah it's
supposed to change your life like the
god
yeah the god dose or something [ __ ] i
don't know yeah like
like what's that what's the deepest like
craziest trip you've ever been on
and would you get out of it uh it's
probably when i ate mushrooms with my
mom we went to coachella
and i didn't know how to really dose it
all like that so i took a [ __ ] ton and
she took a lot of them too
and outcast was playing and we just have
like this cool relationship with outkast
because
when she we would go on road trips we
would always listen to equipment so i
was like
top five album all time oh yeah hell
yeah so we like outcast coachella
we're doing shrooms hell yeah and we
took the shrooms and they were
really really really really really
really really strong and
we were both just like laying down in
the grass and [ __ ] like that
and it was cool it wasn't too much but i
couldn't move i didn't want to move and
i think the the deepest and realest
thing that i took away from that was
just the fact that i
at one point was inside of my mother's
stomach and i was like wow we were like
connected you know what i mean
like so when we were laying down i'm
like we're basically doing the same
thing we're used to hitting us the same
because we're the same
[ __ ] person i'm like this is this is
deep bro
and it you know you're always going to
be cool with your mom
of course but that's another thing and
your mom for people don't know
like where's his mom will be at the
functions for sure like your mom's
your mom's a g for sure for sure so it
just yeah it definitely gave me a cool
ass appreciation for
for moms that's crazy yo it's crazy you
mentioned outcasts i know you you've
always been
extremely uh high on paying homage to
the people who've
influenced you you've got the bone thugs
tattoo you know what i'm saying like
um obviously you and snoop are you know
i don't know what we call you you guys
are like hip hop tag team champs for the
last 10 years you know like when you
guys do that tour it was like
it was crazy no it was amazing but like
um is there someone who
you know you mentioned outcast and
outcast especially andre
kind of not the most accessible and also
really accessible at the same time
because you might see andre at like
7-eleven and be like oh [ __ ]
sharing ubers and [ __ ] but um is there
someone who
who you looked up to that you haven't
because i feel like everyone you've
connected with cam you've connected with
a lot of people or someone who who
uh you really looked up to that you
haven't really got to like
forge a bond with yet um i was cool with
dmx
uh rest in peace i didn't get to do no
music with him
um i wouldn't i definitely was trying to
do a track with him like
because i seen him at snoop's compound
we were both locked in for
like two weeks i was in one room snoop
is in the other room and
swiss and dmx were another room so we
were just mix and mingle go upstairs
play pool be in the kitchen eating
together so
we were supposed to collab like during
that time but we were just all just
getting high and having too much fun i
know i was
but uh so i didn't get to work with x
um and jay-z i wanna i definitely wanna
you know be in
be in the room with him even if it's
just one track but i feel like
you know just on a building type of
level cracking some jokes he's in a
weird game now
um he's chopped it up with burns so we
got some mutual friends and [ __ ] like
that
so definitely hove yeah how was how was
it um
hanging out with dmx i met him once and
he was like exactly who i'd hoped that
you know
dmx dying man probably just as a fan
obviously nip passing away really hit me
hard because i knew nip right but as a
fan as a kid you and i are around the
same age
i remember going to the hard knock life
tour and leaving after dmx got off stage
this was like volume two hove so he
performed a couple songs that we left
but that [ __ ] really [ __ ] me up cause
i'm like man this dude was like my world
for like sixth and seventh grade yeah
x was crazy bro like i had i remember
walking to the store to go get his
his first album what a single before the
album even came out
i i had black kid at me dog and
when the album came out like that [ __ ]
was so far i remember my dad took it
away from me because it was too explicit
but then he ended up giving it back he
was like no you could listen to this one
this one's dope like i [ __ ] with x
like but just cooling with him he's he's
so he's so much fun i have family from
new york
and he acts just like them like right
now just really outspoken
if you walk in the room he's gonna [ __ ]
with you like i had a cameraman at this
time
he was like yeah i know you you you
that's my camera right there thank you i
i didn't even know you you knew i wanted
one like you know what i mean just
[ __ ] with [ __ ] like
he was a real real cool dude real fun
person to be around so
yeah yeah hey you mentioned jay getting
involved in the weed game
now jay's not uh no like i don't
i don't know jay-z but i don't know him
to be a smoker
no so well not before i think you know
more and
more now than ever yeah i mean you know
you're
one of the biggest weed icons in hip-hop
history
so when guys like who who are kind of
coming from the outside of that world
come in
like like how do you feel about that
well
when there's people like hold i i don't
i would never feel no it's like a boss
move almost
it's like yeah of course of course yeah
why not not why it's like that's like
him getting mad because i don't want to
be a rapper
sit down little [ __ ] i got this it's
like nah [ __ ] that
but that's like i understand he probably
you know wasn't
at the forefront of it or like you know
putting in the work on the
on the side that we were but to
be faces of it you dig what i'm saying
and do it the right way i think that's
the real goal
and just the i see the end goal and the
more
you know bosses and big people and jay-z
has a lot to do with um
you know the jail system and the laws
100 man
so um the fact that there's people right
now
across this country that are doing like
serious prison time for like
minimal amounts of wheat is insane still
so he don't know how to he don't even
have to smoke a joint
i'll smoke it he'll smoke it for him
yeah just just keep us good
i mean you're on your way to like i mean
i feel like you've been making so many
mogul type moves over the last decade
like you know
you got the [ __ ] on post mates yeah hot
box box hot box by whiz i mean there's
just so much
stuff that you have your hands in liquid
death
liquid death pfl
um i'm on tv uh i got a show called
dickinson that's on apple plus i play a
character
his name is death i haven't gotten apple
plus yet i only
you know what's funny is when you
dropped your uh was it last year the
year before behind the camp
yeah that was the only time i got i i i
i got [ __ ]
i think i i got everything but apple
yeah but i was like i gotta go watch
this
it's all good but so is the show on
right now
yeah it's in the second season oh yeah
see i didn't even know that [ __ ] yeah
we about to drop the third season well
we about to start filming the third
season i leave to
you have iconic rapper actor moments and
i mean that in
the most respectful way possible i
appreciate it where it's like
i wouldn't say you're you you've had
moments where you obviously weren't a
great actor right
but it just worked that's what they
called me to set to do
it's like nas and belly they did it just
like be me
nas just showed up and was just nice in
the movie
and that's what yeah after what movie
was it where you were on a [ __ ] horse
that was a movie with with amber yes
yeah yeah and she was like it was like
there were some other girls in there it
was like the gang of the gangs of roses
me and my me and my uh girl watched that
[ __ ] and we were like
this is hilariously bad but it's good
but that's what you got to do though man
like
look at like samuel jackson look at this
[ __ ] jackson was in
everything everything and then he became
the goat later but he did
everything all the way up into that
point you'll watch some old [ __ ] like he
got [ __ ] killed
he was a junkie like he's he's he i
think he's been killed way more times
than he's actually maybe than any actor
ever
yeah samuel jackson's been murdered
multiple ways
shout out to him yeah by multiple races
of people too
so not just you know in the 70s like he
got older and got killed too
um let's give some can we give some
flowers to uh
to burner man yeah that's my dog bro i
think i have a big burn burn
is uh doesn't get enough love when it
comes to just like
yeah that mother man he is he's built
he's built a lot
that's the thing i think i think burner
actually does get enough love he's just
so he's just like the real goat like
when you're really the goat
you don't really see you're here or
anything like that but he's always
putting in work and all the bosses go
through burn
like i just seen a video with rick ross
on burner's
cookie tour bus you know walking him
around his dispensary that he just
opened in vegas
yeah you think what i'm saying it's like
and shout out to rick ross because he's
a boss but
burner's not no loyal [ __ ] you feel me
and that's like you said the reason why
he gets his fliers
that's facts man talk about taylor gang
um you know obviously
one of the most iconic brands in hip-hop
i mean you know
from having juicy j on the label i think
back to that double xl cover where it
was
it was you juicy j was it
native american vibe yeah but like um
americana vibe
you know who is currently on the roster
who who are you excited about
i know you have some new artists yep we
got tons of new artists you're always
signing a new artist yeah i feel like
excuse me so we still got ty and juicy
chevy of course
um burner of course the new artist uh
escape
he's about to skate nice guy yeah
skate's real awesome working
um i started i've known skate for a very
long time because he used to share a
manager without alden smith from the
49ers
which is random all dude that's a good
crazy kid that's a crazy boy
he's a wild guy he just got back on the
thing he's like yeah he's going down
he had jay glazer helping him get this
interesting camp but not bruh
i love him i'm glad he's doing great but
skate
i really was like okay i see you on some
white boy [ __ ] when i saw his you know
he was dating
the girl of the animal i said i see you
bro making us look good out here
cause i i i too am a white guy who's
with a girl who probably most people
would be like
nah that ain't his house you know what i
mean so i respect escape smooth man
yeah good dude man so who else besides
skate skate um
young daisy he's from houston he he
actually created the woe
we were just talking about him yeah yeah
yeah oh y'all y'all up on daisy yeah
there you go uh sosa man he's from
houston as well you got the h-town [ __ ]
locked up mm-hmm
uh chris hollis he's from pittsburgh and
uh fed the guard he's from pittsburgh as
well
pittsburgh is uh obviously you know
that's the shout out to will who yeah i
don't think we'll ever move back
yeah i know man he used the pandemic an
excuse to go home and now he's just he
skated on us bro he just slipped
he was just on the zoo i taught him like
yo when are you coming back he's like
hopefully never
nah he come back it's cool though he did
his time here
it's like jail yeah he did his time he's
allowed to leave
um well [ __ ] man uh everyone should go
obviously
support i mean you got so much stuff
going on and you're working on new music
um you've always been known to kind of
do some collab projects here and there
is there any any of that kind of stuff
in the works yeah me and juicy got
a smacker bro really yeah we got a crazy
album and we got a crazy single for it
already
so yeah that's just gonna be sick would
you and ty ever do another project me
and ty are working on that album too but
he's doing one with mustard
and i feel like that's more of a
priority for him well the last project
y'all put out i think it just was on
soundcloud
no well we did move it to apple to talk
about it in the morning oh it was
it's on apple it's not on spotify though
right no i think it's on spotify we shot
a movie for that too that we never even
released
so maybe we'll dig dig that back up out
of the uh
out of the archives but yeah me and ty
are gonna do an album after him in
mustard
every summer we get a tour from you
usually yes i was going to talk about
that
what's going on with that let's talk
we're going to move it to the fall okay
so that tour is coming
the tour is on the way we're figuring
out the lineup
mm-hmm and it's going to happen in the
fall so that so
so so is it for people i mean you've
ever i feel like every summer we get
whiz and
a plethora of amazing other artists
right there's going to be somebody new
uh last last tour we had jack harlow was
the the big opener and you see what
happened after i mean i remember when
uzi was the first like [ __ ] i know what
i'm saying
you're pretty good before him it was
kendrick wow
yeah money bag yo is open mm-hmm yeah so
we've had some
we've had some really iconic uh
movings on up in the rankings
so it'll be fun to see who comes through
this year and then who smashes it
afterwards
i would like to see blast open i think
blast is the next guy out of the whole
west coast
and i think i think the blast opening
slot on a whiz tour would be nice okay
you know what i'm gonna put the
intentions in the air yeah i don't know
i don't know no i'm always like i'm
i ain't tripping yeah i mean you know i
think uh i'm trying to think who else
who who are you [ __ ] with that's like
that you're like yo i like
let's say there's a new artist that
you're a fan of right now that calls you
and you're just gonna do the future just
because you like them
everybody everybody yeah i like
everybody i love everybody
then there's also the fee so rappers if
you got your bag right
i don't charge you yeah i'm a listen i
need that swap because when you go
number one
no no no no now you have charged
recently
i set up a play for you and you got a
bag off it oh
because it was a bag on the table it was
a nice bag there was a bag on the table
i'm not gonna hit you if you ain't you
know what i'm saying especially for like
well i want to say thank you to you
because you did a record for my artist
in 2019 and uh this [ __ ] went we hit
like a thousand spins at radio
we we that man that was a hell yeah
shout out to brown boy mode alexis that
was yeah that was a fun time
yeah very fun time i'm we always there
because
it's a relationship thing like you all
you got to be able to depend on somebody
so if you want to work we could work
what you working with
hey let me ask you this what's one of
your records that you
wish would have been bigger that you
like was like man this is that [ __ ] but
it just never really
hit like one of your big hits let me
think
i'm like you got a bunch of them to be
honest but they've got to be one that
sticks out
for uh i can't really say because if it
don't
go as crazy i just let it go i don't
really trip off of it
i had a lot of songs i could have could
have picked up i feel like the record
with gucci was crazy
that song was insane i may probably
still went gold or platinum you know
what i mean i definitely have a plaque
for it oh you've been the record uh with
um that pull-up
the pull-up i thought pull-up was gonna
be like a number one record
now it also you got a plaque for it i
have a plaque for that it's a great
record
but yeah that was i think that's the one
that always stuck out like i was like i
remember talking to beat out like
yo this is this is out of here i
remember going in offices and like
dancing on tables to that song i always
put the intention out there and the
energy there and
everything has to do with politics and
and you know
whatever [ __ ] all that performance see
you
see you again at kobe's thing man how
tough was that because that's
i mean were you even nervous to do that
yeah i was nervous that's a moment
i was nervous uh it was rough too man it
was like
it was hella people in there but it
didn't feel like it just felt empty in
that [ __ ]
and that's like a big honor you know
what i mean that's like a big
to have to do something like that huge
honor yeah so i was like all right just
you know
get through it make it make it what it's
supposed to be
it's about him you know what i'm saying
him and his family so
um yeah it was crazy you got a record
like see you again and it's almost like
i mean it's one of the biggest songs
ever uh
isn't it like the biggest song in
youtube history or some [ __ ]
biggest rap song and it's it's
it's a it's a forever i call it like
certain type of records are just forever
songs
you know there's like songs that you'll
hear at every wedding or you and that's
just the forever song like
a hundred years from now that song we
played at someone's funeral i mean like
did you get tired of that song nah hell
nah he said nope hell no that's the goal
man
i want them types of songs bob marley
has them songs
you know snoop got them songs prince got
them songs
where's got that where's khalifa got
them songs
hey what do you what do you think you
know we always hear the term mixtape
whiz
you know we've had so many classic
moments man taylor older guys we
mentioned cushioned oranges earlier
what is the do you even see a difference
in like your mentality when you're in
mixed
tape whiz mode because that's a fan
thing that was made up yeah
like i could agree with the fans on that
just from
like stepping out and then looking back
in there's there's a mixtape whiz just
like there's mixtape wheezy
yeah mixtape wheezy something else
though you know what i'm saying i think
um there's a freedom to doing mixtapes
and that freedom is
slowly you know dying and being uh
pulled back away from us it's because
you can't release music you can't throw
the same way you used to be able to
because
no one's on the clearances everything
has to hit the dsps now
oh my gosh yeah and and literally if it
doesn't reach the dsps it don't exist
yep and that's not cool like well that
just happened with no ceilings three the
the
little waymix tape i feel like we got
that record with drake on the dsps but
other than that i don't know
anybody who was like riding around on
that piff and shout out to that pitch
we're still using that i dropped three
mixtapes this year on that piv
already yeah they just don't exist i
mean not to downplay that but it's like
in the world and in music consumption
it's hard it's it's hard
fans aren't trained these days like we
were where we're like yo i gotta hit
that piff right
you know what i'm saying i gotta hit
soundcloud and then the same fans will
ask for mix tape wiz or mixtape weezy
we'll drop it on whatever platform that
we can drop it and they'll be like
when you put in on apple music and it's
like dude
just get the [ __ ] project is there
any plans to
put some of the other classics up on uh
spotify because we got i mean look we
got cushion orange juice that's all that
matters
it's a process because a lot of those
beats have samples in them that
that won't be cleared and i don't want
to put out
you know incomplete projects and things
like that so
it takes a minute to really go back and
like monetize all of that [ __ ] and
that's why we've just now released the
thrill as a regular song oh the thrill
you know that song's been out for what
10 years and it just now
is starting to you could track what it's
doing like whatever
[ __ ] is crazy would you ever go indie
whiz yeah
i mean you've been with atlantic for so
long yeah it's been a good marriage but
you know i feel like uh
you're the kind of artist that can i
mean you have an infrastructure and a
team and
every relationship possible and i feel
like you going independence and that
inevitable man
i would i don't want to speak before you
know my relationship
with atlantic is over with i still got a
couple albums to do with them
but in the grand scheme of things you
don't
need a lot of that to do yeah things are
different than they were when you first
started right and i'm still
cool with all of them i love julia sure
i love everybody in every department the
radio
marketplace of course i love everybody
they treat me so well over there
um but yeah uh
you just don't need you don't need to do
that stuff no more
all the bells and whistles it comes with
a major it's like a lot of that you
could do yourself
especially when you've been in the game
especially when you're wiz khalifa come
on now
i've been in the game for a minute a
newer artist i see i see the the
the the need for all of that you you
you're still in training you know what
i'm saying you haven't even had your
superstar moment yet
we didn't even we didn't shout out your
gin either oh yeah amazing
mcqueen i'm surprised i should have
brought some from home i would have took
a little shower with you
man a little little day the mcqueen is
amazing by the way yeah good luck
i'd like to thank you too because i
never now me and my wife's go-to drink
is gin and lemonade there you go which i
never would have discovered if it
weren't for partying with you guys in
the bombay days before there was a
mcqueen
yeah but we're not going to say that now
we're only [ __ ] with mcqueen now
mcqueen and lemonade take it to the head
thank us later yeah uh vegas residency
is probably gonna be
picking back up soon i'll start on june
4th i just put up the flyer
june 4th of dre's uh tour this fall
tortoise fall liquid death liquid death
pfl
hot box by whiz mcqueen god damn
yeah taylor gang records duncanville
what's duncanville oh the tv show on
apple plus
yeah yeah there's nothing this guy can't
do man man
oreo commercials with his son
am i tripping or did you launch a a
company based around your son
did he do like a clothing line or
something yeah yeah i mean [ __ ]
shout that out yeah yeah the bash
clothing line we about to be
uh re-released for the summer the bash
clothing line is definitely out there
this guy man come on man and also
khalifa kush
khalifa kush would you a wiz i feel like
you could pretty much beat most people's
asses in hip-hop would you ever do the
celebrity fighting thing if trailer hit
you with like a [ __ ] stupid bag
you never know man i'm not gonna say no
an mma fight not even like a boxing
fight because boxing's different but i
feel like you're well versed i would do
i would
definitely do kicking and punching like
it wouldn't just be hands
so if we can get a fight set up based
off of who wants to do
do all of those the right rules with the
right person
i don't see why not run the back hey uh
who's second place to you in fighting
skills that you've been around i know
ot's got you know he's been in there a
lot
i haven't spoiled ot yet he's he's like
he's i feel like ot is like
you know real short little [ __ ]
stocking every time i see him
oh t could hold it down for sure but but
who's someone else in hip hop you think
you know that they got hands like
that you respect who can move in the
industry
let me think let me think let me think
let me think let me think
let me think i'm trying to try to run it
in my head
i don't really um i give it to ot cause
i train
what about an athlete you've been around
like as far as like maybe a football
player a basketball player or something
because i know a lot of people train
over there
i'm like the top of the top of the food
chain over there yeah yeah ain't nobody
eating like me over at that gym club
there it is i can come down though and
y'all can see what's good
come to unbreakable we offer we offer
sunset right behind pink taco
all y'all rappers get you all bagged
together come
get a membership get your body right
let's train
and then we could spar we could hit the
max we could do all of that stuff and
you mentioned protein powder too yeah
yep so you got protein powder coming in
yeah yeah
i got my own protein shake it's gonna be
in gnc and all that oh man
yeah yeah all right well where's khalifa
thanks for coming through no doubt
thanks for having me